breaking news out of Baghdad and Iraq's
president Barton Saleh has just named
Adnan Sufi as the new Iraqi Prime
Minister's or if he's been tasked with
forming a government within 30 days as
the country tries to overcome months of
political deadlock more on this with
Simona Fulton in Baghdad take us through
well who there's new prime minister is
and what he needs to get done well
president Barham saleh has made an
unprecedented step choosing at nuns of
PS prime minister-designate without the
consultation of the political parties in
Parliament this is a quite vague area as
far as the Constitution is concerned
because what the Constitution says is
that the president should nominate
somebody who is chosen by the biggest
Block in Parliament but if that person
does not get this is not able to form a
government the president then chooses
another nominee now what is not clear if
that other nominee can be chosen by the
president directly or if that nominee
still needs to come from the political
parties and what we've seen here in Iraq
over the past month is that the
political bloc's have been excuse me
unable to come up with a name that gets
widespread support from above the
political side but also from the streets
now unknown Zulfi he is currently a
member of parliament as part of the
nostril alliance this is a party that is
headed by the previous prime minister
haider al-abadi he's also somebody who
served as the governor of Najaf in 2004
at that time under the US administration
led by Paul Bremer so he's somebody who
is seen as having pretty close ties with
the West and with the US specifically
and as a result of that many of the
political parties in Parliament are
likely to reject him we've already heard
statements from some of the parties
yesterday and today one of the political
bloc's led by former Prime Minister
Nouri al-maliki said they will not
accept any nominee who does not have the
support from the political parties have
also heard from Kai's cazali who is a
part of the Fatah bloc which is probably
the biggest Block in Parliament at the
moment and he's
that given the crisis that is going on
in Iraq with the protest we have rocket
attacks that are ongoing but also the
coronavirus there should be a state of
emergency that is declared and the
caretaker Prime Minister Adel Abdel
Mahadi should remain in the caretaker
role until the foreseeable future so it
appears that at least among many of
these Shia parties there is a lack of
support for a nun's or fee it remains to
be seen what the Kurds and the Sunnis
will say they have not yet come out to
voice their opinion but for now at
Nana's or he will have 30 days to form a
cabinet and that cabinet then has to be
voted on in Parliament but given the
statements that we've already heard come
out from these various political parties
it's questionable whether he can secure
that support and with that this
political succession crisis that we've
seen in Iraq for months now is likely to
continue
Symone a full team with that update from
baghdad thank you